all right people we are live on rumble
on youtube on blaze tv and i'm still
dave rubin and today we've got another
friday round table extravaganza for you
joining me are the hosts of newsweek's
the debate josh hammer the senior
meteorologist for fox news janice dean
and host of the liz wheeler show liz
wheeler welcome back to the reuben
report everybody
thank you for having us hi dave
great to be here dave i just said
welcome back but josh this is your first
time so you're under a tremendous amount
of pressure i have two i have two aged
veterans on the other side of this and
then a new guy
i'm schvitzing over here i don't know if
you can see me but he's sweating out
he's freaking out all right well uh i
want to recap the week with with you
guys you know it was another nutty week
every week it's another nutty week uh
but a couple things that i wanted to hit
on this week were cnn and chris cuomo
because it's just such a perfect example
of corrupt media and how they're in on
it with the politicians and always
covering for themselves and all that
stuff we're also going to talk a bit
about this mississippi abortion case and
how this may or may not affect roe v
wade and then finally uh the biden
administration may be doing some things
that that scary orange man had talked
about related to mexico and borders and
everybody's freaking out uh so let's
start with the the chris cuomo situation
over at cnn i've got some info here from
uh cnn directly uh when chris admitted
to us this was the statement that they
released uh after they had temporarily
suspended him when chris admitted to us
that he had offered advice to his
brother's staff he broke our rules and
we acknowledged that publicly but we
also appreciated the unique position he
was in and understood his need to put
family first and job second however
these documents point to a greater level
of involvement in his brother's efforts
than we previously knew as a result we
have suspended chris indefinitely
pending further evaluation
and janice i want to go to you first on
this one because in the last two years
you have become maybe the leading critic
of andrew cuomo this was very personal
to you if you want to quickly recap your
story there but does any of this uh
surprise you that now he's actually
suspended and do you think he will
remain suspended
it's a good question
uh i've talked to some sources over at
cnn that say that he wasn't very well
liked uh and many of them couldn't
believe that he hung on till this long
and so we saw it in black and white with
the text messages that he was actively
trying to smear the women that were
going against his brother uh and you
know he likes to say well he's my
brother and of course i'm going to help
him but he lied
he lied to the audience he lied to his
bosses
he lied to everyone until it was
actually
right there uh from the investigation
from the ag report
so and i think the chorus was so loud
from all of the media which is you know
one of the reasons why i started
speaking out is because at the very
beginning a year and a half ago there
were really no media outlets covering
andrew cuomo and his mandate to peco but
positive patients into nursing homes and
actually i am grateful for the calm the
cuomo brothers comedy hour that began on
cnn for weeks because if it wasn't for
that i wouldn't have been so angry
you know my grief literally turned to
anger and the day after the big cotton
swab episode
i went on tucker carlson to tell my
story because
there he was with his brother while
thousands of new yorkers are dying
joking about covid tests which weren't
allowed in nursing homes to test
incoming patients so this has been a
long time coming uh you know ethics
there have been no ethics when it comes
to the cuomo brothers being on
television um you know i i guess there's
always the possibility for chris cuomo
to come back i hope he doesn't he
doesn't deserve to come back and just to
be clear janice uh your pa your uh
in-laws both died of covid because they
were in these nursing homes conor can
you just put that image up again we've
got the image of these two during their
their comedy hour as you put it and this
was at the height of the pandemic as all
of these people were dying on orders by
andrew cuomo and there is chris cuomo
with his giant q-tip and they're just
laughing it up uh josh you're a critic
of mainstream media um does any of this
surprise you like i was on fox earlier
this week and they were asking well are
you surprised do you think that you know
he'll come back and all that and it's
like i'm not surprised at all why would
i expect a quote-unquote journalist at
cnn to be doing honest reporting
especially when his brother's involved
but that's really secondary here i think
yeah it is secondary but i mean it's
also important too right i mean like who
in their right mind dave could have
possibly foreseen that chris cuomo
acting at a time as a major nighttime
anchor on a major cable news channel
while at the same time his brother was
leading the state that was hard to save
from club i mean who could have possibly
foreseen that there would be like a
massive conflict of interest here you
know and look
who who in the right mind could have
possibly seen this happening right but
look there are a lot of people on our
side you know a lot of them friends of
mine like my good friend jesse kelly
i've seen jesse kind of defend chris a
little bit you know within the bounds of
reason same thing he's looking he's
looking out for his family first you saw
that in the cnn statement i i actually
sympathize a lot with that family
obviously should come first the problem
is that if you want to put your family
first and you're in a situation like
chris cuomo found himself and you have
to resign your job or you have to like
you need to take a furlough leave of
absence or do something where there's
not just this brazen conflict of
interest there but it's your broader
point dave look i mean at the end of the
day obviously this is this is cnn okay i
mean like
do we even remember like the old like
cnn like like the advertising they're
running at the beginning of the trump
presidency like this is an apple this is
not fake news we were gaslight for four
years and look the whole thing is a
travesty i mean janice has you know did
amazing work obviously on the cuomo
brothers issue so thank you for your
service in that respect janus but none
of this should surprise us really at all
i don't think liz do you think he's
going to get his job back because if you
want to talk about white male privilege
as they're always talking about it's
like there's a gillion people who would
kill for that time slot and although his
ratings are pretty decent by cnn
standards they're they're pretty much
garbage i mean fox has something like 27
of the top 30 uh you know slots in the
ratings if you care about cable news
ratings it's like why wouldn't they just
get rid of him and give some give
somebody a chance i mean a little
diversity
well listen if we're looking at cnn's
track record then chris cuomo will get
his spot back because they allowed
jeffrey toobin um the disgusting creep
who masturbated on a zoom call a company
work call they suspended him and then
allowed him back on air so if we're
looking at cnn's track record here then
yes he will get his slot back once the
mainstream media has managed to bury
this story but i i just want to pivot
back to what's most important here
obviously chris cuomo is a total creep
obviously he is a stain on the word
journalism a you know he's he's a
journalistic hack a partisan journalist
a hack and i would push back against
jesse kelly i actually did on my show
this week against tucker carlson echoed
this a little bit too and josh did just
a little bit today not quite as much i
don't think there's any virtue in
the idea of coming to the defense of
your family member when your family
member has allegedly committed a crime i
mean if my brother robbed a bank i
wouldn't come and try to cover for him
if my sister had a dead body in her
trunk i wouldn't help her hide it you
don't help it's it's not putting family
first to help somebody who just happens
to be blood related commit a crime or
try to cover that up or try to ruin
somebody else's life so this this
narrative that's coming from cnn that
chris cuomo just got confused about his
priorities that he was just putting
family first no absolutely not this
whole thing is a distraction from what
janus very heroically exposed at the
very beginning and janice by the way
your in-laws must be so proud of you i'm
so proud of you you're a hero for taking
down governor cuomo because the crux of
the matter is the most important thing
here is that he sent thousands of
elderly people in the state of new york
to their deaths by forcing nursing homes
to accept coveted positive patients and
then he tried then he lied about it to
try to cover it up we shouldn't let cnn
become a distraction from that
janet speaking to what uh liz just
mentioned i mean even though andrew
cuomo was taken out in essence because
of the the sexual assault allegations
you must be feeling pretty good that
he's not the governor although actually
the governor that this this new one this
what's her name uh
abby hokel
i mean
she's in some ways far more
authoritarian than even he was but but
how do you sort of generally feel about
the fact that he is no longer governor
after after you did so much work to
expose him
i wish she was impeached uh resignation
is not impeachment it's not
accountability and i think he struck a
deal uh with carl heasty the speaker and
uh some of the lawmakers because i think
they told him listen you're you're about
to be impeached you need to do the right
thing and resign if you resign then
we'll stop the impeachment process we'll
stop the investigation which is what
happened once he resigned they recently
um you know
released all of the paperwork that they
were undergoing with with the
investigation
but they stopped it and they stopped
short of the nursing home issues imagine
that um so
listen although it's great not to see
his face on television every day uh i
still think there needs to be
accountability there are still
investigations by the doj and the fbi
into the nursing home
situation the fact that for months and
months he covered up the numbers to sell
his 5.2 million dollar book which was
written by state resources
so all of those things are still under
investigation and of course his horrific
behavior with women josh does this story
the cuomo brothers story kind of lead
you to like well everybody in the media
mainstream media is kinda in on it like
you're either reporting on your brother
or on an administration you used to work
for or on a press secretary that was
used to be your assistant or just like
almost everyone is so deeply connected
in the media to the people that they're
reporting on it's like this is all just
obvious isn't it so it's really not just
the mainstream media that's in on the
act here it's really kind of just like
the broader like ruling class more
generally in this country i mean if the
people who are giving out emmy awards
are willing to kind of completely
overlook everything that jazz was
talking about from the very gecko about
the nursing homes and all that and give
this man an emmy at the same time that
he was going around writing a book about
his triumphs on this subject i mean the
whole thing just stinks to high heaven
dave i mean like i i everyone should
really kind of be up in their arms about
that and look i i agree with with
everything that janice and liza said i
mean hopefully chris cuomo does not come
back to his perch but i sadly predict he
probably will to be honest liz even
though this is sort of good for us
watching the mainstream media collapse
and then the alternate alternative or
whatever you want to call it the online
media grow it's sort of depressing right
like don't you wish these guys were a
little bit better i always say it's like
they don't have to be great i just wish
they weren't like abjectly horrible yeah
i don't call it alternative media i call
it honest media because that's what we
are those of us who are independent like
you and i we are the honest we're trying
at least yeah and i mean when we do make
mistakes we own up to it we correct
that's because we're human beings that's
that's acting with journalistic
integrity um even if we're opinion
commentators but yes the the reason that
it's so upsetting to see the mainstream
media outlets lie
um and
carry water for the democratic party act
as the propaganda arm for this radical
leftist ideology this marxist agenda
that the left has is because it's not
truly a
matter of just competing with these with
these companies right you have you have
this sort of crony capitalism that goes
on and i don't need to tell you this
this is exactly what you're doing with
locals you actually are working and
fighting to be a competition to big tech
which is another another of the same
another in this same category as the
mainstream media that is simply trying
to stifle conservatives but it's not
really a fair playing field so you can't
just bring your opinion to the court of
public opinion and have it compete
against the left you can't necessarily
start a cable channel and just compete
against cnn because there is so much
crony capitalism whether it's the cable
providers who own some of the cable
channels whether it's you know the
government making it possible or not i
mean it's not really a fair playing
field and so it's very hard to compete
so it is frustrating when you know that
there are many americans who their only
source of news is this you know this
lying this lying leftist media hey i
guess it gives us all something to do
when we wake up in the morning so uh
that's that's pretty good
all right let's uh let's move on to the
second the second story which really was
the big story of the week uh the supreme
court heard initial arguments about this
mississippi abortion case which
basically everyone is now saying could
lead potentially to a reversal on roe v
wade we've got some info from the daily
wire on wednesday the supreme court
heard arguments concerning a case
regarding a mississippi abortion law
that could have massive implications for
pro-life laws around the country the
case dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization concerns a 2018 law in
mississippi that bans most abortions
after 15 weeks of pregnancy as the law
stands now roe v wade and the decisions
that came after it hold that states have
to allow a woman to be able to get an
abortion up to the point of viability or
when the baby can survive on its own
outside the womb most states hold this
mark at around 20 to 24 weeks
josh i want to start with you on this
one i saw you at the national
conservatism conference
the roe v wade decision generally was
one of the big things being talked about
and how much the courts will get
involved in all of this and will it get
to the supreme court and everything else
uh what do you make about the arguments
that we heard in the last couple days
yeah so from my vantage point dave this
is kind of like the legal constitutional
issue of all constitutional issues it
has obviously deeply divided america for
for literally the past half century roe
versus wade you know was january of 1973
so we're coming up on the 49th
anniversary of it it was famously um
largely a firm 19 years later in the
1992 case of planned parenthood versus
casey and the dobbs case out of
mississippi and the underlying statute
is basically a 15-week gestational ban
on abortion with limited exceptions for
after 15 weeks but that's basically the
statute it does directly put in its
crosshairs both row and casey and this
is the best opportunity that pro-lifers
have had
for a modicum of sanity on on the
abortion issue really since the casey
case in 1992 and you know i listened to
the entirety of oral argument i mean
from kind of a pro-life and really as a
constitutionalist perspective because
you know as your very well-informed
audience obviously knows roe vs wade was
completely concocted i mean like they
made up a bunch of crap basically the
penumbras the emanations all of this was
just totally philosophized from the
bench in pretty egregious fashion here
and the the very modest claim that kind
of the anti-rose side or at least most
on the anti-rose side make is that the
constitution doesn't speak to this
matter and that is properly an issue for
the for the 50 state legislature so some
of us actually do go a little further
than that but the kind of neutral middle
ground position which is on the
mainstream i would say constitutionalist
perspective is that the constitution
just allows this issue to go to the
states and i i personally was actually i
listened to the entirety of oral
argument on wednesday i was quite happy
with what i heard to be honest with you
i mean even justice kavanaugh who i
think is considered one of kind of the
swing justices on this case really kind
of came out swinging i mean he seems to
have intuited that this leave it to the
state's position is the neutral middle
ground position here so
i feel confident predicting that they're
gonna find a way to uphold the
mississippi statute the million dollar
question is will it be some some sort of
like muddled kind of incremental you
know john roberts special or will they
actually go the full way and actually
overturn all of it i but i i will say i
have a lot of friends who even some
friends who clerked on the supreme court
who were texting me afterwards they were
they were really happy with what they
heard it probably couldn't have gone a
whole lot better honestly yeah and for
the record i discussed this with liz a
couple weeks ago i mean i do consider
myself begrudgingly pro-choice really to
about 12 weeks
without getting too far down that road
but i do kind of understand this
position of this is not an a
constitutionally guaranteed right so you
should kick it back to the states i
don't love making that argument uh and i
i get the i get it on both sides but i
that makes sense to me janice what's
what's your take on this
listen uh the divided issue right we're
already uh a united states that is
divided and this one is going to divide
us more uh when you look at somebody
like kathy hokel who is saying
come on down to new york city uh we're
open for this procedure whoever wants it
i mean that's that's difficult to hear i
i have two children i am catholic i am
pro-life uh what i don't want to see
is this as a substitute uh for birth
control i don't want teenagers to think
oh well you know i can go out and do
this and and i have so many things that
i can go to including this option which
i think is terrible um and i have so
many friends that are craving for babies
in their life they can't have children
for whatever reason and they are dying
to adopt uh you know i think if
education goes towards other options of
having a child and giving it to loving
family members i think that that's
really important and and i wish that we
would we would get to to something like
that where we have more education to
here's something that you can do you can
have a child and give it to a family
that wants one so badly
yeah well said i mean solutions it's
like if there were more non-profits i
know that many of them exist but if
there were more nonprofits that would
help women who say did not want the
child for whatever reason get that child
to to be adopted or fostered or whatever
maybe that helps a little bit liz is
there any middle ground here like this
is just the one because it brings up
philosophical issues and scientific
issues and religious issues all the
existential issues they're all on the
table here we can't agree on basic
things anymore that two plus two equals
four so it's like is there anything we
can get to on this
well listen the american people i mean
if you if you ignore
the elected officials in washington dc
on both sides of the aisle the american
people actually agree on this issue over
80 percent of the american people want
abortion banned in the third trimester
over 60 of the american people this by
the way is both conservative and liberal
pro-abortion and pro-life one abortion
ban in the second trimester the
overwhelming majority of people do agree
on abortion they do want restrictions
it's just the very far left as
politicians who ignore that but i echo a
little bit of what josh said i listened
to the entire argument it was about two
hours worth in front of the supreme
court and i was shocked actually by how
weak the arguments from the pro-abortion
side were their arguments were
essentially two-fold they argued that
because it was quote-unquote settled law
it's precedent it's been you know law
for what like almost 60 years um that
it can't hurt yeah it's just which is
ridiculous i mean that's completely
contradictory yeah to our entire legal
history i mean look at something like
plessy versus ferguson that was
overturned by brown versus board of
education that was about racial
segregation so that argument doesn't
hold any water and then their second
argument was um an argument just about
woman a woman's choice a woman's body
yet they didn't mention anything about
the baby's body which is the
the competing legal interest as we all
know here i thought the arguments from
that side were actually very weak i was
very encouraged after hearing this um
after hearing these arguments and it was
very interesting to hear what some of
the justices said some of the swing
justices how robert was roberts was very
interested in the idea of viability
kavanaugh was very interested in the
idea of the supreme court being neutral
on um on the question of abortion these
are very this is going to be very
interesting um to watch very interesting
to see and i know i uh many of your
viewers i'm sure are joining me in
praying for these nine justices after
they've heard this argument we won't
find out until june what their decision
will be
yeah and also i mean i did watch most of
it and i do have to say i thought that
the the pro-life arguments were just
better like it's exactly what you're
saying they were more thoughtful where
the others were because because there
just simply is no constitutional right
to an abortion i mean bernie tweeted it
out this morning and it's like no that's
not in the constitution we can talk
about roe v wade but like it's just not
there all right we got one more for you
guys uh you remember that orange guy
with the funny hair donald trump and he
was always talking about mexico and a
border and all that stuff well now biden
who used to call him racist is sort of
doing a lot of things or wants to do a
lot of things
that trump was doing we've got some info
here from the blaze the biden
administration has reached a deal this
week with the mexican government to
relaunch the trump era remain in mexico
program the program officially known as
migrant protection protocols was
implemented in 2019 under trump and
requires migrants seeking asylum in the
u.s to stay in mexico while they wait
for their u.s court hearings by
establishing the program trump aimed to
prevent migrants traveling to the
southern border through mexico from
disappearing before their court hearings
and thus avoiding potential deportation
i mean that sounds pretty sane to me and
yet of course it was called racist about
two years ago now it's being ushered in
by the biden administration which by the
way i don't know if you guys saw this
but like an hour ago
uh fauci
called it the wuhan virus that was
something trump was always called racist
for too yeah he actually called it the
wuhan virus i just saw it this morning
oh my gosh liz let me throw to you on
this one first i mean we should just
sort of move past the hypocrisy right
like that's not the surprising part here
sane policy is that the surprising part
well listen don't give the biden
administration more credit than they
deserve they haven't come to their
senses they're not reimplementing this
policy because it makes sense they're
doing so because a court is making them
a court is forcing them to and the court
even said that they have to implement
this policy again in good faith meaning
they can't try to get around it here but
i mean this policy is a good policy it
makes sense and i'll tell you why it
makes sense it makes sense because if we
have all of these migrants who are
essentially falsely claiming asylum just
because they want to be released into
the united states um we have to ask okay
well how many of them show up for their
court dates after they have been you
know detained by the border patrol and
then released into the united states and
given a court date told to come back to
have their asylum claim adjudicated how
many of them actually come back well
there was um one particular judge who
said that over 90 percent of the
migrants that she gave court dates to
did not show up for their hearing well
no kidding that's human nature i mean
dave would you show back up i probably
wouldn't be honest in this situation i
wouldn't if i'm being honest they're not
so of course then this is this is just a
soft form of amnesty this is a way of
allowing migrants regardless of whether
their asylum claims are legitimate to
just you know fade into the shadows into
the united states of course the biden
administration didn't want to do this
but the thing is without this policy
what happens is what's happening at the
border right now a travesty i mean the
biden administration's policies on
immigration are anti-woman they're
anti-child and they're anti-immigrant
let and that's not even taking into
account the fact that it's dangerous for
our national security and a burden on
welfare one in three women and children
are sexually assaulted on their way to
cross the border after they cross the
border while still in these cartel
trafficking houses it is anti-immigrant
anti-woman and anti-child to put a
policy in place knowing that it will
lead to the bodily harm of these people
just so that the cartels and the coyotes
can make a buck off of it by the way
it's also basically pro covid because
fauci was asked this week about you know
vaccines for people on airplanes coming
into the country and masks and all that
he's like yeah that's all good and then
they asked him about you know people
crossing the southern border illegally
he's like well that's something else i
mean it's just so bananas josh bananas
by the way what he said
it's not true what fauci said fauci said
that there are some people that are
getting tested it is not a widespread
policy you can ask any border patrol
agent any ice agent this is not a
widespread thing they are not testing on
any kind of large-scale basis no you can
just see the video that they only show
you on fox actually with just thousands
of people and they're not social
distancing either uh josh i suppose i
suppose you're not surprised by any of
this
no i mean look we all remember the
videos from del rio texas which of
course was like the big hot topic of the
day just like a month and a half two
months ago or so here i mean the body
administration has they've been
disastrous on a lot of issues obviously
i mean afghanistan the withdrawal there
was particularly egregious i would say
but i i'm holding aside like perhaps the
afghanistan kind of crap show really
immigration the board in particular has
been the one area where i think they
have consistently and repeatedly
errored most egregiously here and this
is totally right to mention that they're
only doing this on a
literally due to a a judicial decree and
they from from a very good judge by the
way uh judge kasmir and amarillo texas i
was very i'd probably say i was very
briefly colleagues with him before he
was tapped for the bench he's a he's
he's a wonderful conservative so he did
the right thing here of course but you
know i i've actually talked over the
years with a lot of kind of doj folks
both while i was serving in the trump
administration and vote and afterwards
they literally unanimously have told me
that of all the various policies that
the trump administration put into place
mpp was by far the most effective at
actually stemming the tide of legal
immigration for the extremely common
sense logical reason that is exactly
what liz said which is if you get past
the border we have this ridiculous catch
and release policy going back to the
obama administration when jay johnson
was secretary of homeland security and
when you're releasing to the interior as
liz said of course you're not gonna show
up this is just such common sense so
look i mean i i i guess we could say
good for the blind administration on
this i mean again like they're literally
just doing it at the force of like a
judicial gun i guess in theory they
could like choose to defy the court
order so good for them for not defying
this a completely sane and proper court
order but look
the situation on the border is egregious
for all the parties involved like liz
said it's not just the ranchers it's not
just the people living on the border
it's terrible for them too obviously
but the cartels we're talking here about
about the transnational cartels is the
sinaloa folks like that operating in
northern mexico we are talking about the
most vicious non-state actors in the
entire western hemisphere like these
people are brutal
so we don't want to empower them at all
we should be defanging them at any and
all possibilities and mpp is a very very
simple and straightforward way to do
that
so janna says the person here that works
for really the only cable news network
that's covering this at all and then got
banned at some point i think fox even
had helicopters up there and drones that
then were told they couldn't be up there
do you sense we have any real idea of
the numbers of people that have come in
in the last year whether they have
coveted or not where they are whether
they brought kids whether they're
getting welfare etc etc
i think you know the answer that it's
absolutely we're not we're not getting
those numbers at all and listen i'm
canadian uh and by
by birth i have dual citizenship my
father was american uh i came to the
land of opportunity and i understand
what it's like to want to come to
america and make a life for yourself
because this is the greatest country in
the world uh and i still had a mound of
paperwork to fill out uh to get to get
into this wonderful country so i
understand why these people want to come
here but you have to do it the right way
you have to
yeah and by the way you know canadians
right now speaking of canada cannot
leave the country or get on a plane or
get on a train if they're unvaccinated
do you have family there that perhaps is
thrilled about this at the moment uh it
you know what i didn't see my mom for
over a year and a half we recently saw
her in the summer and the hoops that she
had to go through
she's almost 80 years old and to get
here uh air canada was
a mess because uh they just didn't have
the workers so she was in the airport
for like 12 hours both ways to try to
get here uh and the vaccination process
was really difficult in canada as well
we're trying to go there at christmas
time i don't know if we're gonna get
there because of you know the
restrictions and and and and how tough
it is to to get with with the
vaccinations and and and and their
government
so guys i always try to end my friday
shows on a positive note so people can
put down politics for the weekend and
act like real people and maybe eat food
and see friends and listen to music and
all all that kind of stuff so i want you
to each to give me one positive thing it
can be personal political whatever
that's going to take you into the
weekend liz you're up
oh i'm going to spend my weekend chasing
after my 10 month old daughter who is
fascinated by the christmas tree and
thinks that it is her specific duty to
pull off all of the ornaments so it's
magical and tiring and wonderful
and i met her in orlando and she is
absolutely gorgeous josh
thank you dave
i i'm a huge college football fan
tomorrow's a huge day on the college
football calendar we've got a lot of
conference championship games number one
georgia i think has the best chance to
finally get past nick saban and alabama
they have come tantalizingly close
before i i don't necessarily root
against alabama but it's nice to see a
different team other than alabama win
every so often so i personally will be
pulling for georgia tomorrow lots of
other good games on the calendar as well
so from a sports fans perspective
tomorrow should be a great day
janice now that you don't have to poke
your andrew cuomo voodoo doll anymore
what are you gonna do this weekend
oh i still have that voodoo doll
um well listen uh you know i get up at 3
a.m every single morning and it's friday
so i get to sleep in tomorrow uh so i'm
excited about that we're going to put up
our christmas tree
very nice very nice well it was great
seeing you guys i'm going to finish up
for a couple minutes without you but
have a good weekend and i'll have you
guys all back as soon as you're willing
to come back
sounds good
thanks dave have a good weekend guys
all right everybody that's it for
friday another week down yeah it all
feels kind of nutty but i hope that you
will do exactly what the three of them
just mentioned which is something that
brings you a little joy in your life
whether it's playing with your kids or
watching football or poking in andrew
cuomo or gavin newsom voodoo doll
whatever works for you guys i do want to
mention one other thing which is
obviously this was a big week
related to the rumble and locals
situation the the company now with
cancer fitzgerald went public we have
huge huge plans and as i've said many
times the goal here is to restore a free
a free and fair internet an open
internet where you you're not going to
be censored based on your political
opinions that's what we're planning on
doing uh you know they'll be the
front-ending video side of it on the
rumble front they'll be the the sort of
amazon aws amazon web services
replacement the underbelly of the
internet the subscription side of it all
of it we're working on payment
processors everything else we feel like
this gives us a chance this gives us a
chance i think we've teamed with the
right people chris who is uh the ceo of
rumble retains control assaf who is the
ceo of locals retains control we're
building something great and uh i'm glad
that so many of you are are along the
ride with us so uh that's it we've got a
couple other big announcements over the
next week or two i've been hinting here
i'll send you one of my patented
messages through the pipes
you got it ah some of you got it some of
you got it
good work people anyway have a good
weekend everybody see on monday